chris what's unusual about this to me
last week we got some hints from guys
like dak prescott and tyrone crawford
that this is the way the wind was
blowing
but
ownership still hasn't come out with
that clear
unequivocal
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain forget about everything we said
before we're not trying to thread any
needles we're going to completely and
totally and unconditionally
unequivocally respect the ability of the
players to do whatever they want they're
dancing around and we're going to hear
from jerry jones in a second yeah but
isn't that odd that the way the truth
has come out
hasn't been kind of you know pulling the
sheet off of the rocky statue it's just
been more of a gradual casual
reveal where the sheets still over the
statue and the wind's blowing and you
can kind of see what's going on but
nobody's come out and really said with
clarity this is what's happening until
yesterday well i think you know mike i
don't know you tell me my just like two
cents on that would be
i don't think jerry jones wants to make
headlines with some big statement right
that would probably he always wants to
make i know that's what's shocking about
this you're right usually we get a state
of the union address by jerry jones and
he goes this is where the cowboys stand
and this is what we're gonna do
but this is a sensitive issue
and
we know jerry jones cares about his
african-american players his black
players i'm sure he's had enough of
these guys whether it's past players or
guys on the team right now
and of course he's compassionate to know
what's going on in the world right now
to where hey yeah he want i'm sure he'd
like the team to stand but i'm sure he
has a soft spot in his heart for what
that community is going through right
now as well and i think he's probably
just trying to
let it play out
sunday okay there's going to be guys
that kneel and he'll deal with the
firestorm you know and his next pro
press conference and deal with it that
way instead of you know making a
headline now on wednesday and having a
build up and a fight in the dallas
morning news where everybody's going oh
the cowboys are going to kneel they're
not going to kneel what's going to go on
jerry jo so maybe he just doesn't want
to hear that crap and i don't blame him
i think it's twofold one is the
political reaction specifically the
tweets from the commander-in-chief were
members of his family and there was one
recently from one of the president's
sons based upon what the cowboys will be
doing the other thing too is
jerry jones i believe is a firm
subscriber to the notion that the
customer is always right and the more
right that you make the customer think
the customer is the easier it is to pick
the customer's pocket i mean that's the
reality if the customer is happy the
customer is going to shower you with the
customer's cash yeah and
and he was on 105.3 the fan yesterday
and he did address the issue and he
acknowledged
that he wants his players to realize a
majority of the fans will be upset the
customer
will not be right when it comes to this
but here's what jerry jones also said
about the team's plan moving forward
i
certainly want
fears
and i only have
the that they have the motivation
to if you will
not use
the sideline or use
that part of the game the national
anthem not use that to get people's
attention because that's already been
like
everybody understands the issues
everybody does
i want everybody to understand that if
any player
that is standing out there has a serious
serious
serious
awareness of the kind of
activity there is there and they ask for
help and with that in mind and so that
if they're there to say uh
in a way that you would ask for help
it's not good to uh
be uh uh
observers or anything
if you are asking people to uh see it
through your eyes and see it in your way
it's important to show the kind of grace
everybody where i stand
everybody's got a good feel for where uh
the country is on this matter uh i would
expect cowboys to show uh i'm gonna use
the word great sensitivity
however they do i hope the fans will
receive it in a way that
is a genuine ask for help
because uh uh right now in our society
we've got some things that
we do need to address and i want the
cowboys to
be a part of that
i still think he's trying to thread the
needle he's just trying to thread a
different needle now what he's trying to
do is basically say to your players i
only want you to do this
if you truly feel that you personally
have a need for help that drives you to
break from what i would prefer that you
do
which is stand at all times and any fans
in the stands who may not like the fact
that we have players who are taking a
knee and asking for help you need to
understand they're not trying to
disrespect anyone they're merely asking
for help we'll see if that works now
there's no fans in the stands on sunday
night when they play
the rams in la but there will be fans
the following weekend when they host the
falcons but that's what he's trying to
do now he's trying to get the players to
understand it's a last resort
and trying to get the fans to understand
that that it's nothing disrespectful to
anyone but simply that cry for help that
the player feels compelled to make i
don't know that it's going to fly but
that's my interpretation no i'm i
actually have the same interpretation
you're right he's trying to kind of ease
both sides into this because he's not
sure where it's going to go
now
there's going to be i i would imagine a
number of players who yes they're gonna
kneel because they feel like it has hit
you know the needle has hit red on the
danger meter like okay
i mean how many times do we have to see
the same damn story and in the same
issues so i think there are guys that
are personally hurt by what's going on
in our country and they're going to
kneel and yeah i think jerry jones is is
trying to let his players know there's
going to be consequences and you're
certainly here in texas and people are
going to be mad at you if you kneel for
the flag and he's at the same time
trying to talk to the fan base and going
hey fan base you know you know where i
stand unequivocally i want the guys to
stand you know but i'm also going to
show grace and compassion for my players
and i hope you would join me in that in
seeing this and that it's more about not
just you know disrespect to the flag i
think that's what he's trying to do you
know and i don't i'm not mad at him for
it i'm really not i mean at least he's
trying to pull two sides together i mean
nobody else in our country is so uh in
some ways i kind of like it i i don't
know am i weird for that
well but i don't think you have to work
so hard to try to pull two sides
together because the problem is the two
sides aren't going to be pulled together
if if telling people that kneeling
during the national anthem is not
intended as a disrespect for anyone that
it is aimed at drawing attention to
broader societal issues it's not a slap
at the military a slap at the flag to
slap the country and they don't see that
how are they going to see that oh it's a
cry for help so that makes it okay
you've got that segment that has it
hardwired into their brains that no
matter what anyone says to justify it
it's still disrespectful to take a knee
during the national anthem yeah period
and no amount of talking or fancy words
from jerry jones like obstreperous is
going to make them see it any
differently chris no well you know and
you know quite honestly those are the
those are the people that the players
aren't going to care about they're not
so they're going to kneel the players
never have cared no you're right they
never came but when you lay it out like
that when you lay it out like that and
you start to say it that way then they
just go okay but those those people are
never going to be in this fight with us
so they're going to kneel and just say
the hell with it i mean that's really
what it comes down to and we're going to
see that on sunday night there's going
to be a faction of guys that kneel
here's what it really comes down to
because there will be a faction of guys
that kneel and there will be blow back
over it and there will be blowback over
the names that are going to be
prominently and conspicuously displayed
on the bumper pad at the back of the
helmet once we see those close-ups
during games and you see george floyd
and brianna taylor and jacob blake there
will be reaction to that
what will the nfl do this time when they
come after the players and they come
after the league because they're not
just coming after the league when
there's a tweet from the president or
one of his family members or his
supporters get up in arms it's not just
directed at the league it's directed to
the individual players who are
exercising their right to make their
voices heard and peter king asked roger
goodell about this we didn't talk to
peter about it yesterday but it's in
football morning in america and i wrote
something about it he asked the
commissioner
what are you going to do when when you
get hit with a 2x4 over this and the
commissioner said i think that's a
hypothetical i'm not sure that's okay
come on of course that's what's going to
happen you got to have a plan for it
you're consciously walking into a
minefield there will be explosions what
is your plan for dealing with them and
chris my hope is this
instead of jerry jones talking for three
minutes and using big words and trying
to navigate the minefield right why not
just be ready to engage
if they're going to come after us we're
standing up to them because that's how
you truly have your players backs
silently tolerating what your players
are doing is not truly supporting your
players standing up for your players
when they're attacked from the outside
that
is supporting your players and that is
what the nfl needs to do well we're
gonna see where the nfl stands on that
because it's inevitable and it's coming
and they've had a lot of talk and so far
i believe their talk that they're going
to support the players and make a stand
and do the right thing here no matter
who's tweeting at them or whatever it
may be now i don't know if jerry jones
is going to be that guy it doesn't seem
like that it seems like he's very warm
and cozy with donald trump so i don't
think he's ever going to do that but i
think the rest of the nfl how do you
reconcile that how do you look
stop being political but how do you
reconcile that when the president is
continuously badgering the nfl over
players protesting how do you reconcile
supporting player protests with
supporting the guy who's badgering the
nfl over players protesting how do you
reconcile that listen there's so many
things i can say right now
i know it's but here's the point strip
aside the politics yeah this is a basic
business dilemma there's a person i
support who doesn't support what my
players are doing but i support what my
players are doing how do i
it's i mean it's a basic challenge of
logic and there's no logical way to
satisfy both ends of that no and that's
why you you can't ride the fence on this
you have to eventually pick a side and
what jerry jones is trying to do you
know what's that thing that balance beam
during gymnastics that skin he's trying
to walk the balance beam let's call the
beam right he's trying to he's trying to
walk the beam as long as he possibly can
and it's not going to work because
eventually the players are going to say
it's not enough to just look the other
way while we protest and bite your lip
and brace for the reaction you need to
stand up for us when somebody bullies us
over this you need to stand up for us
when people criticize us over this you
just can't go run and hide like you did
three years ago which is what the nfl
collectively did three years ago yeah
they ran and they hid when the crap hit
the fan yeah well the crap will hit the
fan if they do that again i do i think
the players will be pissed and they're
gonna revolt and i don't know where it
would go if the nfl isn't supportive
this time in a round so i would be very
scared of that what the minefield
is more concentrated this time yeah and
there's and there's there's all
different sorts of minds and if you step
the wrong way on this
what you're going to have is what
happened in the nba and you're going to
have players say we're maybe we don't
play yeah right the owners don't support
support right if you if if people are
going to come after us and call us names
and they're going to be all riled up
into action by the president or someone
who is connected to him and you sit back
and say nothing this time it's going to
get worse not better and and look i'm
not trying to stir up trouble here i'm
just trying to anticipate where the
dominoes are falling and the nfl needs
to have a plan for what's coming because
no plan is not an acceptable plan for
what is coming because you have to
envision that it's coming and you have
to be ready for it and you better
support your players or you're going to
have a bigger problem than having the
president sending out nasty tweets at
two in the morning yeah no i agree with
you totally mike and you you're right at
some point we're we're gonna have to
deal with this i think it's gonna come
you know we're gonna be talking about
this monday morning if i in my crystal
ball if i had to like look at the way
the world's going
set you know segment one we're going to
talk about the games segment two is
going to be
wait the backlash the tweets all the
things about guys kneeling on sunday
and uh yeah it's a shame but yeah this
is not going away especially an election
year and you're right mike the owners
better you know hold strong here support
the players do what's right
i'll see your monday morning and i'll
raise you a friday morning a friday both
both days we're going to be talking
about it because the game starts
thursday night and we're going to see
those names on the back of the helmets
we're going to see bill o'brien
neal feels the way he did a couple of
weeks ago he's kneeling during the
anthem right and see so many of the
things that only the hardcore football
fans have been paying attention to are
going to explode onto tv screens across
the country and casual fans are going to
be jarred by it because they haven't
been paying attention yeah that and it's
coming folks it's coming
and a guy like bill o'brien do it he's
gonna send shock waves which is great
because bill o'brien is a man's man an
american working man self-made and for
like again it goes back into like the
white quarterback white coach
conversation when those guys start to
kneel
uh i think that can have a tremendous
effect on anybody watching and in our
whole country
and there'll be backlash and we'll see
what the league and the owners do about
it this time around will they stand up
and fight back on behalf of the players
and coaches like bill o'brien or will
they find a bed to crawl under and wait
until it all goes away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports